on poursuit avec jonathan la pierre le
maire des îles-de-la-madeleine président
également du comité sur le transport
inter régionale de la fédération
québécoise des municipalités bonsoir
monsieur la pierre
bonsoir monsieur fillon et yves montigny
qui est maire de baie comeau et qui est
membre du comité sur le transport aérien
de l'union des municipalités du québec
bonsoir
non selon ses clients bon alors ça fait
quand même des années qu'on cherche
monsieur la pierre des façons de faire
baisser les prix d'augmenter aussi la
concurrence dans le transport aérien
régional est ce que pour vous
aujourd'hui
le plan présenté vient régler les choses
en fait le plan qui est présenté
aujourd'hui tendent à régler une partie
de la problématique du transport aérien
régional pour l'ensemble des régions du
québec vous savez dupes les deux
dernières années l'ensemble des
intervenants qui ont été impliqués dans
les discussions avec le ministre avec le
ministère des transports or mentionné le
fait à quel point que pour la
tarification ou le coût des billets
d'avion droit exorbitant est un frein au
développement du transport aérien donc
aujourd'hui l'annnonce de
l'accessibilité de billard 500 $ est un
pas dans la bonne direction bien bien
aidé vient souvenez cette vision
d'augmenter le volume du nombre de
passagers dans les différents segments
mais devient pas tout régler en matière
de transport aérien régional d'une
question de dessert elle ne ferait il ya
une question de fréquence il ya une
question de compétition oui de
tarification mais il faut aussi créer
des habitudes de déplacements que ce
soit des régions vers des grands
ensembles où les grands centres vers les
régions est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
vos citoyens
monsieur montigny et pour les résidents
dans le fond des régions du québec parce
que le gros changement essentiellement
c'est d'enlever le plafond aux
remboursements auxquels les passagers
avaient déjà droit est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour vos concitoyens monsieur
montigny
d'abord ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que nous et lapierre a raison il ya des
enjeux à travailler c'est pas la fin en
soi mais d'abord c'est une très très
bonne nouvelle vraiment qu'on puisse
briser le système actuel qui faisait que
c'était beaucoup moins cher voyager en
europe voyager ailleurs au canada et le
mexique
je le comprends mais maurice denis mais
je veux juste bien comprendre est ce que
pour vos résident aujourd'hui dans lever
le plafond est ce qu'on répond aux
besoins des citoyens du québec en région
pour le volet 1 clairement il fallait
enlever le plâtre long parce que pour
pas limiter l'accès aux déplacements aux
citoyens de la côte nord de la gaspésie
les îles de la madeleine fallait
éliminer le plafond maintenant le
deuxième volet aussi était important
parce que on a un prix tout de suite on
a deux nations à 500 $ ca prenaient ça
alors pour les citoyens c'est une très
bonne nouvelle ça va nous permettre de
voyager pour se rappeler qu'un transport
en commun à rien ça il faut éviter
l'auto solo aussi pour les citoyens qui
se déplace au territoire du québec
c'est une très bonne nouvelle c'était
dans les dessertes ou si qu'on avait
avant elle la pandémie alors il fallait
vraiment été rené auque dans les
dessertes qui était déjà présente avant
la fin de tout le monde aime les îles de
la madeleine est-ce que vous pensez que
tout le monde va vouloir aller aux îles
de la madeleine qui va y avoir un
déferlement de gens qui vont arriver aux
yeux de la madeleine grâce à cela mme
sur la pierre
donc je pense que c'est à paul objectifs
qui étaient fixés dans le code
îles-de-la-madeleine savez il ya déjà un
achalandage ici aux îles qui est connu
et reconnu depuis des décennies il ya
trois compagnies aériennes trois
entreprises aériennes qui descend à la
communauté des îles pendant la période
estivale est déjà fort les compagnies
aériennes affichent complet pour l'été
et vous savez une capacité mathématiques
maximale d'accueil durant la période
estivale nous notre défi notre enjeu
c'est d'avoir le meilleur service aux
meilleurs tarifs possibles sur une base
annuelle donc douze fois par année
autant pour la population locale et sur
la population des îles étaient déjà
admissibles aux programmes de
remboursement tarifs aériens vous savez
la population des îles les madelinots
les maliennes qui a bétonné ils
bénéficient du programme de 60% du
rabbin du coût initial du billet d'avion
ce qui dans la plupart des cols nous
amène un coût n'est en dessous du 500 $
donc pour les matinaux le biais
d'alliances 500 $ ont peu ou pas
d'impôts par contre pour la diaspora
pour nos amis nous 20 min pour les
visiteurs crucell qui souhaite un jour
venait aux îles de la madeleine et et là
on pourra venir par exemple l'automne au
pouvoir venir le printemps il y va alors
qu'à d'autres moments de l'année que
c'est aussi agréable que l'était devenu
ça devient un incitatif ça devient une
opportunité
comparable à celle d'aller ailleurs
évidemment la madeleine pour qu'ils ne
sont pas des carrés mais quand même
annuel et c'est ce qu'on vise là avec un
programme que 500 dollars alors est-ce
que l'offre est intéressante pour le
reste du québec également je regarde air
canada par exemple qui vient de réduire
ses services vers rouyn noranda c'était
le 1er mai deux semaines après la
première annonce du plan de françois
bonnardel est ce que monsieur de
montigny le programme d'accès offert une
quelconque garantie que l'offre va
s'améliorer ce que ça règle en jeu de
l'offre
est important le d'abord cet axe-là une
bien raisonnable pour être capable
tellement à prendre le transport aérien
alors actuellement sur la côte-nord la
baie comeau des citoyens ils prenaient
pas la violence d'un produit de luxe
alors que l'homme maintenant ça va être
axé steve ça est excité mais aussi aux
gens qui viennent nous visiter ça c'est
vraiment important alors ça va susciter
des gens a maintenant regarder les prix
pour le transport aérien regardez les
vols disponibles maintenant ça devient
accessible transport aérien ça va amener
de l'achalandage ça va redémarrer c'est
tout vous qui est important d'heures
vous aimerez pas ma prochaine question
mais je vous la pose quand même aux deux
est ce qu'il est
est-ce qu'il faut subventionner tout le
québec doit subventionner les compagnies
aériennes pour offrir des billets pour
voyager en région au québec ou plus loin
des grands ensembles
ils me répondent chacun monsieur
lapierre d'abord
je vous dirai ce que est ce qu'il faut
que le québec subventionne tous des
transports en commun un transport
collectif et la réponse associés
évidemment oui maintenant je tiens à
préciser ce n'est pas tant les
compagnies aériennes convient
subventionné c'est le coût du billet
d'avion donc c'est pour le citoyen qu'on
subventionne puisque la compagnie
aérienne
monsieur la pierre mais la compagnie
aérienne monsieur lapierre la compagnie
aérienne n'offrent paul billets plus bas
c'est bien parce qu'on ne subventionne
qu'on va offrir des billets 500 $ doit
absolument mais il faut quand même se
soumettre à la défense des compagnies
aériennes au québec il ya quand même un
faible volume dans les compagnies
aériennes donc dans les différents
segments il ya un taux de taxation qui
est très élevé il ya un taux de taxation
qui varient d'un aéroport à l'autre
puisque des aéroports fédéraux
provinciaux municipaux donc le cri du
carburant évidemment la rareté de la
main-d'oeuvre les pilotes des agents de
bord les règles de nav canada les règles
de transport canada donc nous sommes un
pays et une province ultra évidemment
conventionnés réglementée monsieur mais
nous coup du je pense que c'est très
beau de nabeul elles sont pas monsieur
montigny le québec c'est grand le québec
c'est magnifique on veut occuper
l'ensemble de notre territoire on veut
vivent au québec partout sur notre
territoire il faut le rendre accessible
que ça soit par avion que ça soit
évidemment par la route mais ça peut
être aussi par transport par autobus
alors c'est important de voir que ce
type de transport collectif doit être
bien financé par tous sur tout le
territoire y compris le transport aérien
en région ces grandes québec vols
habités mais il faut être fier de notre
grand québec et de le visiter ok yves
mounier merci beaucoup c'est comme un
appel vraiment à visiter le québec et
monsieur lapierre également aux yeux
merci merci à vous deux mais si vous
confions pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh